à paris le défilé organisé entre la
place de la république et la gare saint
lazare a rassemblé environ 50 mille
personnes selon la préfecture de police
et 160 mille selon la cgt en tête de ce
cortège les cheminots grévistes
reportage agnès molinier et laurent bay
il diffuse pour la troisième fois
ils sont en grève depuis 11 jours et
aujourd'hui les cheminots sont plus
déterminés que jamais ils durcissent le
ton et les slogans
donc j'espère qu'il va
c'est trois poils blancs j'y vais
l'aborder chine ue en direct
autant je dois l'appel à manifester
lancé aujourd'hui par la cgt force
ouvrière a largement été sur son but se
faire entendre par le gouvernement
j'ai surtout le sentiment qu'il ne prend
pas la mesure de ce qui est en train de
grandir dans le pays
ça oui j'en ai la conviction tous les
moyens étaient bons pour montrer sa
détermination mais surtout pour demander
des négociations du gouvernement
aujourd'hui il sent pas bien ce qu'un
gouvernement qui négocie pas que les
organisations syndicales c'est qu'il va
bien avec aujourd'hui dans les rues de
paris la manifestation deux nuls de
france a drainé autant de monde que le
rassemblement national de mardi dernier
le cortège s'est disloqué à la gare
saint lazare et ce n'est qu'après que
quelques incidents éclatent et néo cons
d'isoler se sont pris à des voitures et
au mobilier urbain